Today I'm going to show you seven ways
to stimulate your stem cells without
having to go to a clinic and go through
any surgical procedure or spend
thousands and thousands of dollars. A
stem cell is kind of like this reserve
cell that can pretty much change into
anything that you need. They're using it
now to regenerate fibrosis, which then
allows the heart muscle function to
improve by 30%. They can do the same
thing with liver fibrosis and damage
brain cells. They're getting great
results stimulating new cartilage in
your joint. Some people are using it for
autoimmune diseases like MS and also to
help rejuvenate skin cells to actually
make the skin young again. There's also
stem cells for cancer. It's very
important to understand how to keep that
stem cell population at the highest
level. Let's start with number one,
fasting, specifically prolonged fasting.
If you could fast for 72 hours, which is
three days, you can in a major way boost
certain stem cells primarily for the
gastrointestinal tract, for your brain
and your immune system. When you're
fasting, you're not eating anything.
You're just drinking water. And you're
basically clearing everything out of
your digestive system. And because
there's no food available for the cells,
they actually start surviving better.
And those stem cells start to repair
damage within your digestive tract. And
the other thing that's going on when
you're fasting, your body is taking
damaged tissue, recycling, and turning
that into new tissue. Intermittent
fasting is important, too. Of course,
it's not going to be as potent as
fasting longer. Number two, exercise.
Exercise stimulates stem cells for your
muscles and your brain. This is exercise
where it's more intense. It's more
difficult. You're using your full body
in a functional way to create a lot of
effort or intensity. And the most potent
stimulus of the stem cell when you
exercise is intensity. If you can do an
intense exercise, short duration, the
more stem cell you're going to
stimulate. When you exercise, you're
also going to stimulate something called
BDNF,
brain drive neurotrphic factor. This is
like miracle growth for the brain. It
allows you to make new nerve cells or
brain cells. The other stem cells that
you're going to develop when you
exercise is the stem cells that help
prepare the inside layer of the arteries
called the endothelial layer. This is
the layer that becomes damaged and then
a person will develop a clogged artery
or inflammation. Guess what? Both
fasting and exercise reduce
inflammation. So that can indirectly
influence your stem cells. We know as
you age the stem cells go down. Exercise
will preserve that to a certain degree.
Number three, deep quality sleep. When
you're sleeping, you're increasing
melatonin. Melatonin increases the stem
cells for your brain. Of course, on the
opposite of that, when you have
insomnia, that can inhibit your stem
cells. Stress inhibits stem cells. A
quality sleep can reduce cortisol
stress, which can then indirectly
increase stem cells. And also deep sleep
will increase your immune system stem
cell. And this is probably why when
someone's sick, the more sleep they can
get because it allows the body to
strengthen the stem cells. Lastly, with
regard to sleep, a quality sleep cycle
can improve the stem cells that help the
cardiovascular system, specifically the
heart muscle itself. Think about it. The
heart has to keep beating 24/7 all the
time. And so, it needs some time to
rest. Well, it keeps beating even when
you sleep. But with a really good
quality sleep, you can actually at least
develop more stem cells to help
rejuvenate the heart tissue itself. And
it's interesting that people that have
insomnia have higher risk of getting
heart attacks. Good night rest can
really help your heart. Number four,
green tea. Specifically, a certain
phytonutrient called EGCG.
This chemical in green tea is an
anti-inflammatory. Green tea, which is a
very popular tea around the world, has
the potential to increase stem cells for
your brain and for your liver. And on
top of that, it can decrease the stem
cells for cancer cells, which is a good
thing. Number five, omega-3 fatty acids.
This would be the fish oils, the cive
oil. Now, the big thing people know
about these fish oils is that they're
anti-inflammatory. So, we already know
that decreasing inflammation can
increase stem cell. But omega-3 has the
ability to increase stem cell for bone,
cartilage, brain, and skin. Number six,
vitamin D/ the sun. Both the sun and
especially vitamin D will increase stem
cells. And people that are deficient in
vitamin D are going to have a problem
with stem cells. And another interesting
function of vitamin D is to help
maintain the blood stem cells that are
involved with your immune system.
Vitamin D increases new immune cells.
Vitamin D also prevents the exhaustion
of stem cells, specifically of the
brain, the immune system, and the
muscles. This is probably another reason
why vitamin D helps you live longer. And
then number seven, cold therapy. I'm
talking about cold immersion or even a
cold shower. But being in the cold
stimulates brown fat stem cells, which
has a lot to do with muscle repair,
decreasing inflammation, helps
supporting the mitochondria with more
blood flow in general, which brings more
nutrition to the stem cells, as well as
boosting a very specific protein. I've
already talked about this BDNF, brain
derived neurotrophic factor. This is the
miracle growth for the brain. And it's
pretty wild because every time I do the
cold immersion, I feel like my brain is
just working so much better. Personally,
I've experienced that. It's pretty wild
that cold helps your cognitive function
do better as well as your mood. I have
mentioned a few things that destroy the
stem cells. Inflammation, stress, lack
of sleep, junk food is another thing.
Alcohol, smoking, pollution, any chronic
inflammation. The last point I want to
bring up is this cancer stem cell. The
stem cells for cancer act very similar
to certain types of bacteria that do not
need oxygen. One way to decrease the
stem cell for cancer is to flood the
body with oxygen. And this is why
exercise is so important. This is why
hyperbaric decreases certain types of
cancer because you're going in this tank
and that you're infusing your body with
oxygen because of what oxygen does to
the nature of a stem cell for cancer.
Adding more oxygen will destroy it. And
if we compare those cells to cancer
cells, we have a very unique difference
in relationship to genes that protect
against dehydration. Our cells have at
least 50 different genes that help us
cope with dehydration. But the cancer
cells have none of those genes. In other
words, a cancer cell is more vulnerable
to dehydration than our cells. How can
we use this information? One of the
things that people do is they do a dry
fast where they're not drinking any
water and they're fasting for a period
of time. In fact, if you look at the
data with dry fasting, you can actually
triple your results. Apparently, it's
more destructive to the cancer cells
than our own cells because we are a
little more protected. Let's say, for
example, on a given day, you're fasting
for 18 hours and you drank nothing or
you ate nothing. That would be an
example of intermittent dehydration.
We're not actually restricting the
amount of water per day. We're just
allocating certain amounts of water at
certain times. It's something to look
into, and I'm just putting it on your
radar. Now, if you have not seen my
video on dry fasting, you should check
it out. It's pretty interesting. I'll
put it up right here.
Before you go, real quick, I have a
course entitled How to Bulletproof Your
Immune System. It's a free course. I
want you to take it. And here's why.
Here's you.
Here is your environment.
Everyone is focused on this over here.
avoiding your environment. But what
about here? What about strengthening
your immune system? That's what's
missing. This course will show you how
to bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist your environment
much better by strengthening your own
immune system. I put a link down in the
description right down below. Check it
out and get signed up today.
Hey,